hello welcome to this video playing a
beautiful mind on art lecture right
Roland rule on throughout yes why does
he have such a bad rating he's usually
rated a lot higher and somehow hmm he
tricked me into this now I wanted to
head to play some green felt now the
fibers rubbish i have to go for a
regular for regular kinks india and can
I do maybe this one I'm not a not a big
fan of this structure but at least I
have played it before with the trade
mmm that's not very ambitious d5 looks a
lot more testing or keeping the tension
with surprise that he went for the
trades here the ship f8 Bishop c5 looks
looks like quite nice hmm it's a very
nice form of the Kings Indian exchange
em at least black has nothing to worry
about
here I wondered if b6 is a move for pro
95 I think I'll go for that it's an
interesting interesting play it wrecks
my porn structure but his bishop is
really bad in the resulting structure
and I was taking a loan valium I came
here we go
one issue with this is that um it's a
very blocked kind of position where
difficult to do anything what a strange
game is taking so long here
hmm okay he's a really good player I'm
god- to score against him that's why I'm
a little bit stunned by the way this is
played out here okay oh interesting move
making up him
hmm I know primos is taking so long here
and all the night is hanging out sorry
it's take
yeah what problem is that can this
really takes on f6 that's probably a
draw the opposite colored bishops very
likely can also go h5
yeah that's very Jewish very droid if I
can kind of maybe anime can do this
to avoid them immediate simplification
and I would like to get my night more
active probably rather difficult though
nope ship to your sick song well okay he
probably has equalized now
yep wants to go to d5 here I mean if he
also manages yeah he does not only want
want to you that you will go there any
way to do anything here maybe the night
over boo yeah just not much happening
say anything I can try him probably not
it's very dry it was a nice position at
one point but here there's simply
nothing that I can try or that he can
try for that matter can i maybe bring
the bishop around doesn't lead to
anything either wait wait wait wait wait
wait now g7 is made I need to go to the
eighth and then then there's everything
doesn't made can I prevent him from
sacrificing this one maybe
I know he's got that one shoot i should
have prayed King age seven him ah that
was suppose bad time 10 it's no maid
anymore some other way this is true this
justice just check huh what a shame
I went and now now I can go to d4 maybe
there's some way to win this is really
defending this stuff now on rg3 mate for
now there's made on g3 and no I wasn't
playing on time there you have some
ideas here I mean this king is on this
is animating net and no it'sit's really
winning 93 autumn hmm very a bit
disappointing after this opening this
this way of playing is really am yeah
very harmless let's aim but he defended
it rather well I think here with this
Bishop g5 at least it seems he's got no
problem here anymore I think him yeah
around here it's just very equal I tried
to somehow keep the game going but this
is just very equal until he put himself
into that self meeting net here that
could at least tricky yeah now I wanted
to us all that but I wanted to I wanted
to really mate and not not even get here
yeah but I should just go for this
pollution it should it should be winning
yes this kind of thing should be a win
it's not easy though
now i'm not positive how I'm winning him
he added the end a small entered this
here he it's made who should be three
Bishop e3 is made yeah okay this this
was a maid as an idea for is a flatmate
he cannot at all prevent it okay well
thanks for watching